I think we have tremendous,
tremendous growth,
tremendous,
tremendous potential in exploring the
frontier of human beings.
We are at just at the very,
very beginning of a very exciting
adventure and think of of diseases as
common cold,
right?
But it's nothing terribly unusual about
common called right,
yet we don't have a cure for common cold
yet,
which is kind of ironic,
right?
Uh,
which means that innovation could be
very small for small things like common
cold or big things like Alzheimer's and
diabetes.
We have multiple products for the
diabetes today.
We don't have acute for diabetes yet.
Actually,
if you add Alzheimer's and diabetes,
it could bankrupt our health care system
yet we don't have a cure for diabetes
and we don't know how to deal with
Alzheimer's yet.
So if I look at the future,
a couple of things will happen.
One,
we have phenomenal tools that will
enable us to diagnose and to be more
specific in better understanding the
mechanism of virtually any disease.
And the second aspect would be based on
that we can start now charter the,
the road to veteran understanding the
brain.
We don't know much about the brain,
we know a few things here and there,
but the brain is a huge unknown
scientifically still.
We don't have a lot of tools yet to
better understand how we think the
memory and everything related to our
behavior,
so the brain will be probably the next
frontier,
but we should not forget that we have
still about 6,000 rare diseases that do
not have a treatment,
so we have a lot of work to do and we
cannot do it alone.
I mean money and investment is one
thing,
but we need to continue working on the
framework of the regulatory agencies and
how we can partner with the regulators
to have a clear path forward to having
the new drugs approved.
The biggest challenge we face is science
is moving so fast that the regulators
have to catch up.
They have to catch up to understand and
catch up even more to regulate us,
which is a very daunting challenge and I
really believe that the regulators are
doing the right things in most of the
cases,
but at the same time I can only see the
challenges that they have to better
understand how the science is
progressing and you hear every,
every,
every day about the genomes and our
understanding of the genomes.
I mean,
this is absolutely flabbergasting the
progress we've made over the last 15
years in better understanding the inner
mechanics of how we work and from that
will come.
New Medications will come,
new cures,
new treatments.